thank you everybody for coming and
welcome to the presentation on planets
for psychic learning pipelines with
Larry
um
so why should you care about tennis in
machine learning patterns in general
well because if you don't care about it
then it can very well happen with your
machine learning pipelines in Spain have
bias and bias in various different
directions to creative agenda Maybe by
race maybe but there is other projects
that have to do this page and so on
and why should we care about that well
again there are many reasons for that
there are laws and regulations which you
don't want to bring hopefully you have
some personal values that influence what
kind of Technologies you are building
probably your employer or the
organization that you work for also has
values that you want to comply with and
then for for organizations across bias
in machine learning is a big deal for
their reputation and thereby also for
their business
now in this presentation I'm going to
focus on algorithmic awareness metrics
and mitigators now that means there's
another incredibly important topic
around bias and candidates that I will
only touch upon the very little in this
presentations which is the society
issues
um now in terms of other energy issues
I'm going to talk about stability
aptitude and like the focus on binary
classification and I'm going to talk a
lot about noisy trade-offs because
that's what you face in reality when
you're trying to interpret fans in
machine learning now in terms of
societal issues
there's no consensus on which techniques
are right there's actually no consensus
on what constitutes fairness and
I can't pretend that I have the right
opinion in that and so what I will
attempt to do in this talk is to show
you various tools and show you various
definitions for PMS so that you can then
Choose Wisely among them
um in fact these these differences that
you will see sometimes go quite deep so
that they can be a capped down to some
extract World Views that people might
have about fairness
now let us start where people usually
start when they have a data science
project which is with a data set and so
there are various things that you can
find out
in the data set
um without any fancy techniques just by
looking at it so for this presentation
I'm going to use as a running example
the so-called credit G data set this is
a data set about loan approvals as you
can see it's a traveler data set it has
1000 rows
there's a label columns Y and in this
case all the labels right in the product
good meaning preserving of credit and
that meaning kind
um that means it's a binary
classification here and then there are
20 features uh actually I'm not showing
all of them on the slide for space
reasons but as you can see among the
features that are collectively called x
two of them are pointed out specifically
as protected attributes one of them age
um is a numeric protected attribute and
then the other one person knows that is
um makes it obvious what the gender
option is and therefore it's it's also
predicted attribute things
and
um now before before you try to even
figure out what device in this data set
is um it's good to um have some
definitions of what you consider
um favorable outcomes and what you
consider protected groups
so
um you can see a little bit of python
code here at the top it's a it's just a
dictionary this python happens to be
also valid as a Json object
um it defines favorable labels as good
so loan approval is a capable thing for
most people and then it defines the two
protected attributes that we already
talked about personal status and age but
in addition it also defines for both of
them which values for that attribute are
considered as a privileged group
you might come up with different
definitions in different vectors and so
on um but let's assume that that somehow
you came up with that or maybe somebody
in your organization came up with that
and now you you need to work with it um
and you can see that the thing is
definition for the categorical attribute
personal status just lists the values
that are considered in the privilege
group versus the the fairness meta data
for the continuous attribute age lists a
range so in this case everybody from age
26 to 1000 is considered privileged
which as you can see
um puts the cut off about here in the
histogram
um and then even in this histogram for
the for the personal status you can see
that the group distribution is actually
quite uneven so there are more male
singers than all female groups combined
in this data set and that's not even
counting the other two main categories
here that in and of itself is may or may
not be considered biased yet but we will
see that it actually makes machine
learning on this data especially when
you're trying to achieve TNS a little
bit more challenging because you will
have fewer instances to generalize from
for the unprivileged groups
now to drill down a little bit further
into this data set another thing that
you can do is you can use membership in
the privileged and unprivileged group
for the two different classes to kind of
split your data set into more clues so
you can finalize the personal status as
zero one and you also can minimize the
age of zero one by using the fantasy
metadata up there and then you can find
out for instance this means May uh old
sorry male and Owings and there are um
there are a total of 605 instances in
that group out of which 447 received a
table of the outcome in this Legacy now
you see that for this group the ratio of
favorable outcomes in the data set was
the largest for a young female the ratio
of favorable outcomes was the smallest
and then you can see for the other
intersectionalities it's somewhere in
between
and um
now this actually brings us to one of
these worldview questions
so
um there are two World Views that are
very articularly articulately prescribed
in attack on paper on the impossibility
of chemist different value systems
require different mechanisms one
worldview is we are all equal
so if you have sufficiently large
subgroups of your population and there
is some systemic
disparity in terms of oh the ratio of
loan application Level of loans being
accepted for once approve is much higher
than for another then if you believe
that we are all equal then there's
probably some structural bias and you
can't really trust the data now another
Viewpoint would be that what you see is
what you get
um so this Viewpoint says I totally
trust my data I believe it's not only is
my data right and in fact correctly
represents reality and if that is the
worldview that you subscribe to then
um what you will strive for is the best
individual accounts that you can get so
if two individuals are equal and on all
their features then we will attempt to
also give them the same outcome in terms
of the predictions
now um
algorithms unfortunately uh have a hard
time doing just one of these I didn't
want to go together in fact it's
impossible in a data set collector one
that we just saw to guarantee both
together because they really you have
two choices either somehow your
algorithm manages to uh to make
predictions such that the ratio of
positive or favorable outcomes is
exactly the same to the two rules well
in that case it has to um sometimes
politically outcomes that you would have
done based on the downtrue because you
just saw in the groundhog the outcomes
very much
vegetable or vice versa let's say you
get an algorithm that somehow met with
the ground group perfectly well then in
mind it it actually is
what's a question give us an example of
a book data set because I feel like I'm
often often in the middle of it we
should always try to balance like that
because
you're supposed to try to create your
property or do your cross validation
like five thousand more important
so um
yeah I think you should uh um so I guess
I have two questions here one is
but then the other question is well what
is what would be fair and
um
again let me let me give an example
um so for uh for Green Card application
in the United States at some point they
had an artery system
and so the lottery system in this
implicitly makes an assumption that well
the only way to make a fierce by not
looking at the individual at all you can
just randomly developers now
um I don't know if I agree with that
with this country I mean that's not my I
I took information decisions
um but uh but at least there seems to be
based on a fundamental belief in uh
all right so these are the axiomatic
assumptions
um now
another thing that you can find out just
by looking at the data set is Future
importances and here I'm actually just
using the socket learn permutation
importance function what it does is it
evaluates the importance of each feature
by permuting the values of the of the in
that column and so if you do that
basically if you randomizing that column
then they will carry no predictive power
for the final model and then you can
look at okay well if I did that and kept
all the other features the same how much
critical performance
and so um I I then ordered the teachers
by the future importance but the most
important feature is at the top uh
checking status seems to be very
important for determining whether
somebody gets along and as you can see
the protected attributes will ages
fairly high up in the future and four
things uh personal status seems to be
kind of roughly half the way down
um so they do carry some predictive
power over the final outcome
now one idea on my path is okay well if
if we want to make things Fair why don't
we just remove these two features and
then train our classifier problem solve
now um the next set of data will show
you that that's not likely to succeed or
not that way to have the desire that we
want to get participated from that so
here I again I'm plotting future
importance but not feature importance
for predicting the target label instead
I'm following future importance for
predicting the binary rights predicted
attitude so for instance for personal
status I'm trying to predict zero one
from all the other features
and so if I look at all of the other
features and I'm trying to predict
personal status then apparently the
credit demand is the most critical
feature which I don't know why that's
that's what the data gave us age
apparently in this data set is also
strongly correlated for whatever reason
um and then similarly if you just look
at the other predicted attribute I mean
housing status is highly predictive of
Nature and that is maybe less surprising
because uh depending on where people
look around and have different kinds of
housing situations
and um so but really the take home from
the takeaway from this is that um since
you can use the other features to
predict the particular languages
um just removing the protected altitude
doesn't guarantee that your model is
really fair because it might still
make like a disparate ratio on outcomes
all right so that's I mean there could
be more things that people can find out
from the data about uh but let's move on
to metrics so why do we need metrics um
well uh as we just saw this data set is
biased probably any
python that you built for this data set
won't be perfect in terms of DNS either
um so the question really comes okay how
do you compare two pipelines in terms of
how good they are in respective parents
and that's what you need to the fans
um of course you can also use metrics
more actively kind of arithmically so
you can actively optimize for the metric
and to do that of course you have to
pick which one and since there are
different worldviews there are many
um now before I get into that The
Pianist metrics let me just
um cover a little bit of background just
um predict this performance metrics for
a second one so in fact it learned
um there are apisometrics and then
there's boring apis and you can see in
line two for instance I'm creating a
score from the cycle to unbalancing
accuracy metric um
you might wonder why balanced efforts
instead of just vanilla accuracy the
reason is that this data set is so much
in Balance to begin with and so if you
just optimize for accuracy then then you
might do quite poorly on the less
representation
now
um once you have instantiated this
e-score variable line 3 shows one
straightforward way you can just pass in
the pipeline and the data set and it
will speed up number
uh then lines five through eight show
one place in the second one API where
these kind of scores are typically used
and that's for cross validation so in
Cross validation you're passing in that
order and the data set and the pipeline
and then uh one more thing that you have
to specify is you have to specify some
cross validation approach
I recommend strike fight K4 cost
validation for for this kind of
categorical Target label data set
um
and then finally another place where
scorers show up in the second 2018
selection and again
um
the VA score that are instantiated
earlier shows up as an argument now I
love psychedon unfortunately it doesn't
actually come with internet metrics it
comes with all these accuracy metrics
and so we built this open source Library
where we provide some PMS metrics that
are that can be passed and impact in the
same case it's pretty good
and um
specifically in this talk I'm going to
talk about uh five of them
and these are all based on different
assumptions of what you want to
accomplish so the first one this word
impact
um
you can let me just read the formula for
you and it works so this spread impact
is Quantified as the likelihood of
getting a favorable label
given that the instance is in the
unprivileged product divided by the
likelihood of the favorable for
instances in the privilege
in other words if
um if
individuals in the unprivileged group
have a lower rate of favorable labels
than this number will be below one if
these two groups have exactly the same
rate of favorable related within the
method will be one and that indicates
perfectly clearness as part of this
metric is concerned
um you can actually also overshoot in
the other directions where
there was a case actually that went to
court in the United States and where the
judges basically decided that on an 80
table they said well if one group
um gets only 80 of the thousand of our
country from compared to another group
then that constitutes bias and has been
fixed and of course that that is in the
other works in the other direction so
now um You might want another possible
metric is something called this metric
that's worth impact which basically says
well anytime that the number is about
one you just divide tickets
and
um
the advantage of that is then it's only
one threshold
um so it will uh it's more readily
useful for algorithms that try to
minimize
um of course I mean as I compare these
they're really good arguments to be made
for any one of these and again it
depends on your own personal views as
well as the views of the organization
and the lawsuit in which you operate
which one is
um statistical parity difference is
almost the same formula as here except
that there's a minus sign so you're
subtracting the rates instead of
dividing the rates
um this equal opportunity difference is
is slightly different so it
checks for True positives so when the
predicted label and the ground truth
label are both positive
and it checks the rate of those true
positive so the true positive rate for
the unprivileged group and subtracts
then the true positive group for the for
the privilege sorry true positive rate
for the privileged group
um now again
whether true positives are the right
thing to optimize for Depends entirely
on the circumstances so uh so in some
circumstances maybe it's uh it's a good
thing to optimize for True positives uh
in some other circumstances maybe false
positives are the one the thing that you
really want to avoid at all costs or
false negatives or whichever one it is
right
um but yeah so this is the definition of
the Equal Opportunity difference and
then finally I'm also including a field
index which is the expectation for uh
for
um but for this Matrix purpose is
defined as the benefits the benefit is
the the predicted label mines regardless
so it basically says well from the
perspective of an individual
benefit is the highest when they get a
positive outcome even if the labor was
negative so that's a very individual
Centric metric and as a matter of fact
when you look at this formula you can
see it does not look at the protected
attributes it doesn't consider the group
membership whatsoever so it's a fairness
metric that is really subscribing more
to the busy week mindset and we are all
equal mindset because it completely
ignores whatever protected attributes
might be in the data
um one last thing I wanted to point out
with these metrics is that um
uh
uh these top three
do not mention the predicted labels they
basically just have one y they don't
have a y hat and a different y uh
practically that means that you can
evaluate use this metric to evaluate a
data set even when you don't have an
estimator for it yet so you can evaluate
the data set and figure out okay what is
the bias in the data and then you can go
and evaluate an estimator and you can
see okay what is the bias in the
predictions of the estimator and then
you can even compare the two and you can
say oh this estimator made reduced bias
or increase bias
so um just briefly I mean we already saw
this as a fairness info uh definition up
there and in our API the way to create a
symmetric is where the impact story is
by just passing this fairness inflow in
uh using
um the python tablets that are
positiveness keyword arguments
and once you're done with that you have
this di score and you can pass it to
your grid search or your cross
validation or your randomized search or
whichever API from circuit run you want
to use
all right so let's try it out
[Music]
um
on the left you see
the pipeline that you might use for this
data set so in this data set maybe you
want to protect all the categorical
columns and one hard encode them
project out all the numeric columns and
min max scale them and then concatenate
I guess the features from from those two
subpipelines back together and then you
might want to try various different
classifiers on the pre-processed data
over here on the right
on the x-axis I'm showing symmetric this
version pattern so the further right the
more fear according to this metric
on the y-axis I'm showing balanced
accuracy so the further up the the more
accurate according to this method
and so really that means in this diagram
the further you can move in this
direction it is
and um note that these estimators don't
inherently try to either improve or uh
degrade again this
um but they do have that effect
nevertheless even though they don't plan
because they are completely upgraded to
that and so as you can see in this
experiment
gradient boosted trees from from circuit
learn
um kind of landed at the highest
accuracy but on the other hand K
neighbors landed at the lowest accuracy
but uh but the best fairness and you
have these other points in between
uh unfortunately you have to take this
scatter plot with a big rain outside
which is the huge paragraphs
um and so these error bars you can see
there are error bars in both directions
um the error bars for accuracy are
actually limits smaller than those
volcanoes and um I've actually seen that
often for many different data sets and I
think the reason is that accuracy is
always measured over the interior in
this case as opposed to fairness which
is Method over subgroups or with respect
to subgroups and as you saw these
subgroups were really sort of lopsided
so uh so they're they're out of those
one problem those only 100 or
2002 which which really increases these
error bars
um I guess just methodologically I
should have mentioned okay so I did um
10 runs in each one I did a random split
of 75 of the data for training 25 of the
data for evaluation uh for these uh and
then the error bars are showing the
standard deviation and the dot is
showing the uh the arithmetic mean
oh one more thing that I need to mention
this dot down here
um it's labeled dummy so this is
specifically the Cami classifier from
secondary so second term is a dummy
classifier and what it does is it always
just clicks One Nail in this case it's
always pretty interesting
which means that by definition It's
Perfectly Fair it
whether whether a row belongs to the
privilege group or to the unprivileged
group or any intersectionality of those
it always believes the paper of the
label
um so it doesn't make any difference
based on that so that's how you get to
one on the fairness side on the other
hand on the predictive performance
balance accuracy at 0.5 because it's the
balance of the accuracy of the two
groups
of this uh well okay it's it's I guess
it's
20 percent less accurate than the best
classifier in this example
um the other thing about the dummy
classifier is
um no error bars because even though I
managed 10 times that everything else it
was quality as this matter
all right so now that we have some
metrics we can actually
at the time we can look at fairness and
pipelines so how do you make machine
learning pipelines more fair and the
answer one answer is by using what's
called bias mitigators and so let me
give you a little bit of a background on
some of the bias mitigators in a in a
package called aif360 apms360
um
one of them is a disparate impact
remover what it does is it looks at each
of the non-protected attributes and it
shifts its distributions so that if this
one attribute just looked at the look at
in isolation is Decor related
um
so one one example for that would be
um I've heard that for military
admissions tests there are these these
uh these physical fitness tests and
physical fitness tests might have
different threshold values for male and
female applicants and so this is really
I guess an instance of well another way
to think about that is that you're
Shifting the threshold based on the
group membership
um
rewaying is rather than kind of going
vertically and changing the values in
the columns it goes horizontally and
changes the weight of the roads and what
it says is well if in the unprivileged
group there were fewer positive outcomes
fewer favorable outcomes in the
frivolous too well let's take some of
those theoretical outcomes and weigh
them more heavily
so that overall the classifier that you
trained from that has seen more of their
favorite outcomes than it would have
otherwise and ideally you you calculated
exactly so that so that the total weight
from those two groups
um again I'm presenting these things uh
I think there's a big debate we had for
each one of these whether it's the right
thing
um but but you can't really make a
decision without understanding what they
are doing right so um calibrated equal
Arts post-processing
um uh instead of changing the data
before it gets fit into training it says
okay let's just train something and then
change the predictions of the classifier
happening
and what it does is it basically looks
at the decision on where it looks at um
well the here's an individual in one
group
um but for fairness in the country say
the positive outcome but for pain as
maybe it would have been more fear the
negative outcome or vice versa and so it
flips some of the discrete decisions uh
using a biased coin uh so it basically
randomly picks which decisions to fit
um there's another one called rejects
often classification which is very
similar but it makes these clips deep
humanistically and in both cases they
are trying to make exactly the random
options
um so that in the end you have plans
um all right so these are some of the
um
uh some of the algorithms you can use
for mitigation
and here's how you would use them in in
our Lally Library which is kind of a
wrapper around both circuit line and
then this 360 Library
um maybe let's look at the picture up
here first so displayed impact remover
it's a pre-processing
mitigator so it changes the data before
it even gets used for training and in
this case
um what it does is it you still want to
pre-process your original data say with
the one hot encoding and the min max
scaling and so on but only for the
non-protected attributes on the other
hand in order to do its mitigation the
disparate impact remover actually has to
retain the information about the
protected attributes because it is using
them to make its mitigation decisions so
um so the mitigator basically shifts the
distributions after all the data has
been turned into numbers and scaled and
So unappropriately based on based on the
protected attributes and then the
outcome of that becomes uh the input of
the gradient boosting classifier or
whichever final classifier you choose to
put into the pattern
now in code
um it kind of looks similar so the
digital impact removal over here is the
outermost coil is one of its arguments
or I guess two of its arguments I should
say do because of the star is the
fairness information this is the exact
same fairness information that we use to
instantiate metrics earlier
and then
um another argument is the
pre-processing subpipeline which goes up
here and then finally uh so this greater
greater symbol in Lally it's a it's the
type combinator it basically says pipe
the output from what you just did as the
input into what you're doing next so
we're piping the output from uh from the
disparate impact remover into the input
of the gradient boosting classifier over
here
um I should mention one more combinator
which is the and combinator which
basically uh says well here's this one
sub pipeline you do one thing here's
another
thing there independent and then they
can be I guess the output from both can
be packed into a concentration operator
all right anyway so how do these bias
mitigators do
um so for this experiment I created a
choice of Pittsburgh impact remover and
all the other bias mitigators I showed
on the previous slide and then finally
reject option classification
um and then I created this exact same
plot that we saw before and in fact I
kind of as a baseline included the
non-mitigated gradient boosting
classified so there's no metadata in
there and also the dummy classifier
dummy classifier is still the most Fair
um
the good news is all these bias
mitigators seem to have shifted
um the predictions to be somewhat more
obvious unfortunately the values is none
of them have
in America
um and then the other thing is uh
I guess calibrated equal arts
post-processing for the particular data
set didn't work all that well on the
other hand the other three uh display
impact remover rebelling and reject
option classification and then you can
see some differences in their experience
and in their predictive performance but
really it's it's almost nice because of
the of the young bars
nevertheless for the rest of this
presentation I am going to pick the
redirect option classification
um
even though it's noisy it's a fairly
lacking candidate for having
accomplished the most for this benefit
all right so
um as you saw this this pre-processing
block in here and you might want to put
different things in there and so
um specifically one of the things you
might want to change is how your
encoding categorical values and so for
this experiment I'm including 100
encoder and ordinal encoder both of
which are in circuit learn and then I'm
including a couple of other encoders
which are in the category reporters
package which is another package on the
competitive package
um just to see okay what what impact do
they have on the predictive performance
of the final model of the engineering
and as you can see
the hashing encoder for this data set is
really that idea because it's both net
sphere and less accurate or it leads to
a pipeline that's both the sphere
hangless accurate than using the Adobe
processor on the other hand with the
other encoders
um
the differences seem to be fairly small
maybe Target encoder has a little bit of
an edge adhesive product in this to this
experiment again every all the error
parts are based on advancement
Okay so
now one other thing that I want to
showcase basically uh
let me actually step back a little bit
so much of the DNS literature so if you
look at academic papers on famous
mitigation
um
pronounce cleverly algorithms with a
camera map that goes into them
that works for data sets that are
completely numeric and simple estimators
and might not necessarily be directly
useful in the context of a darker
pattern and so that's why here I'm
showing okay well what if you wanted to
do all the pre-processing for
categorical features this is how you do
it and so the next step I'm going to
show what if you also want to do
ensembling and so
um you might want to do for instance a
backing ensemble
and there are lots of different options
of what you could try so in this case
I'm saying well let's do a bagging
Ensemble where you have a destroyed
impact remover with a gradient using
classifier and in fact it's a backup
Style
um so the motivation for that might be
that begging also numbers often reduce
noise and as we saw this this these
error bars are pretty big and so so
there's some motivation to try to
squeeze them down right and then um for
the other example I'm showing okay well
what if you wanted to do a stacking on
something so the idea for stacking
Ensemble is the heterogeneous unsounded
where you're doing uh you you're using a
heterogeneous set of different uh base
estimators in this case I'm going to use
a cautionary space decision tree
classifier gradient boosting I think a
nearest neighbors oh yes
oh one minute ago okay it was the one
minute finger all right maybe I uh thank
you
um
uh so maybe let me get to uh to a couple
of things here so uh actually just I
mean the results show that uh banging
and starting didn't do all that well for
this data set the reject option
classification without any ensembling uh
still came out on top
um now another thing you might want to
do is automatic machine learning so
um
so trying to use say location Optimizer
for instance to make the choices for you
now there are a bunch of challenges that
you have to deal with and one of them is
that well now you're trying to optimize
for multiple objectives most patient
optimizers will be optimized for one
um I'm going to uh to deal with that by
just uh combining both the square
symmetrical impact and balance accuracy
and then another issue is well all these
these big errors uh they really get in
the way
because ultimately I was trying to
optimize something and then what if it
doesn't even know which uh whether two
points are where they are with respect
to each other and um so I'm basically
using kind of uh standard practices of
well you use K40 cross validation you
can even repeat that to get the error
first down a little bit another idea is
to stratify not just the outcomes but
also by the projected attributes
um I'm going to skip this slide because
it's very cold heavy
um but over here is basically
uh we are doing automl over the choice
of both the encoders and the final
estimators
and we are finding that
um according to automl this pipeline did
missed according to automl this pipeline
was the second best
but as if as a matter of fact
um uh they're kind of hard to compare at
the the neither of them dominance the
other in a Pareto argument sense and and
the third pattern is this one over here
but the good news is um the automl did
manage to find a point that uh that is
both
um reasonably Fair compared to the other
experiments that we saw before and um on
the higher end of all the accuracies
that we have seen before
all right so to conclude
um
fairness value judgments are very
important I have given you various
backgrounds to how to think about that
I I'm not an authority on top of making
them work
um
but uh
whatever judgment you arrive at the next
step is okay how do I accomplish that
and that's where you want to know the
algorithms and so in this talk about
data Finance metrics Navigators
all these experiments in this talk are
based on our open source Library called
learning there's a URL I encourage you
to try it out and if you want to pitch
in and copy it that's always
thank you
[Applause]
we have a couple of minutes for
questions
but I see the exercise
um
sometimes the accuracy also improving
you think the Improvement is coming
around so that's a great question and I
don't really have a good answer it's
just a little surprising because most of
the time mitigators unfortunately create
accuracy
um the Improvement seems to be fairly
minimal
um so maybe it was nice but my theory
thank you
yes of course
there's a lot of things there are a lot
of things
are very much are you interested in
seeing those metrics you can pick their
life cycle or are you missing but oh
that would be fantastic yes
I would love that because that is kind
of it has a relatively models to solved
Psychopathic views very widely and so if
those metrics work since I can learn
then a lot of people would not have to
go out of their way to use them anymore
relatively similar
um now there is one place so this slide
shows two combinators the pipe
combinator and the amp combinator now
there's a third combinator that we have
in Larry that uh for which circuit run
doesn't have an equivalent and it's the
or combinator the or combinator for
instance on line 13
um introducing as an algorithmic choice
and uh and for Automated machine
learning it's nice to be able to
concisely express that
I guess
um so this is this is the API for
admitted through doing choices is that
yeah exactly okay
and then maybe since I'm on the slide I
want to pitch one other thing is you can
see that I left off the hyper parameters
for gradient boosting classifier for
instance and that's the Syntax for
saying
um
right just not saying what they are
the basically five minutes before
Shuffle time because the next session is
one last question oh sure
and that that's so that to me that just
made this symmetric
um the spirit impact are about the data
but not about the models then why do you
still choose to show
it's your turn to the symmetric metrics
very impact as the fairness metric when
you're evaluating between accuracy
operators
to the data that you get by taking the
prediction that's why
so the predictions because because you
can take the predictions of the model
and you can use those as Y and plugins
still when you're doing a metric
exactly
all right thanks a lot everybody sorry
for staying on